what people do when they don't have an
argument all right
let's get started everybody
as you know if you want updates for me
you know what's Pearl doing what events
am I gonna throw whatever
sign up email list in the description
it's just a Google form right now you
can put in your name and your phone
number
um you can put in one if you don't want
to put in both but I was like I might as
well ask for both right
but you should sign up because I'm gonna
do a Meetup in London I'm going to the
US next month I'm probably gonna do
meetups in every city and I'm gonna send
texts and emails as a reminder of where
I'm gonna be and like what meetups there
will be security don't try anything
weird okay good all right what they do
when they don't have an argument
now
you know I'll say things and when I say
things it's really just an analysis of
society okay there can be individual
benefits that do not benefit Society so
I'll give you an example women voting
all right
as an individual woman getting the right
to vote
yeah that's that's good for me I get
more of a say right but when you look at
it in a societal level
women have no skin in the game game you
know honestly I I would be okay with it
just being people that are enlisted in
the military voting
you know I'm I'm our tat net taxpayer
something like that but when you have a
bunch of women on benefits voting
on decisions that they don't have to pay
for why why would you do that like if
I'm gonna that's like all right that's
like me the owner of a company picking a
CEO and all of the people that are at
the bottom voting on if I get to pick
them
so what
people in my own space will do oh wait
you know what I'll wait I'll also make
analysis of society okay so I'll say
you know we are as women we're older
than ever before
and we're asking for better outcomes so
we're asking to be treated traditionally
but we are not traditional women now
people think I'm insulting them I'm
saying we're older than ever we're more
ran through than ever we're more and I
we're we're um offering them less
children than ever so because a woman's
you know a woman's biological imperative
right what does women want she wants to
be with the King what does the king want
a bunch of concubines so
Rich marriage is like you know
I'm gonna say I'm not gonna get with the
King fine I won't be his concubine I'm
gonna make it work with you my guy and
the guy is like you know what fine fine
I I'm not gonna sleep with the whole
town I'm just gonna get with you my gal
now normally the the compromise was that
he got the Purity and the youth he got
the young virgin and she got the
faithful man so that was both of them
but now we got no young virgins anymore
now guys I'm sorry
I know
I know I'm I'm not a virgin or I I know
I know I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm just you
know and
so a lot of people want to say pearl
well you're not
and I'm like look I'm just giving an
analysis of society there can be
individual benefits like me voting
that I benefit from but when analyzing
it on a societal perspective
they're not the best things
um I'll give you another example they're
like Pearl well you work you have a
podcast
I do enjoy the podcast right I do enjoy
you can't tell me that if you got to
give your opinions on the internet
and people liked listening to them look
it look it don't
don't hate the player hate the game all
right
now
I'm not saying women shouldn't vote I'm
just giving an analysis of society that
when women went into the workforce
um now you have a girl working for a
different man
and you have one household that could
vote for separate like it's just better
when the family's all on the same page
and you know I grew up like this in a
family business and there's pros and
cons to that let me tell you there's
pros and cons but
I you know my dad all my mom also hired
her brother my dad hired his brother and
it's like bringing family like everyone
has a vested interest in a family
like
you work for family or you work for a
stranger now pros and cons I know that
can go poorly you know there's falling
outs your brother's not working
but
where
you know that's not my point my point is
this
when they can't attack the analysis of
society
that women are offering less all right
women and the reason that Society is the
way it is
is because of women all right and then
they want to say oh well the men are
addicted to the video games and addicted
to Corn well who's in the corn
who had to decide to do it first now you
could say well a man produced The Corn
well he'd have to get a girl to what
agree to it
agree to it because the girl that's what
she has to offer she's giving away the
Purity here's the Purity and
that is not to say that is not to say
foreign
that you know the men managing it had no
part in it but let's be honest you know
I know there's a man in the corn out too
you know I just hit corn but but who's
the valuable one let's just be honest in
in the scene right who so who's really
selling their value the woman the woman
so if you're gonna blame like everything
in society that's happened really
I mean I don't want to say
the way dating and relationships is
today is because of women
it's because our standards are too high
for what we offer and a lot of the guys
will be like wow women don't have as
high as standards as you say it's just
the women on the podcast the average
American spends five hours on their
phone a day five you're telling me that
is no influence in society and culture
and two we're seeing more and more
sexless men one out of three
you're telling me
one out of three men being sexless
doesn't indicate that maybe the women's
standards are getting higher and higher
now you could argue
and men need to do more right now but
from a guy's point of view I'm gonna do
all this I'm gonna do all this stuff to
get laid learn how to talk to him and do
all that for what
I don't get a virgin anymore so when you
look at it from an analytical
perspective
understand why the men are walking away
and look look
you could say I'm contributing to the
problem all right that's what they'll
all do personal attacks
pearls37 I am not stop saying I look old
okay maybe it's true all right you know
I I could I could improve
my sleep habits you know
but
my shows are at night you know what I
mean anyways anyway so that's not the
point
think about it to them
and I'm like why
do I need to defend my life choices to
like to the internet
why do these people need an explanation
when we are just talking about Society
and that's that's what they'll do that's
what they'll do
now
I'm not even well I probably said it's
good or bad you know like
but
I'm just giving an analysis here and you
can take it or leave it
but the other thing oh Pearl's not smart
that's the other one
pearl is dumb
okay
hey hey stop my dog sit sit sit sit
chill chill out chill Pearl's dumb
you know
I am sure
done a lot for someone that's an idiot
because that's all they'll say if they
can't tell you why you're wrong attack
your argument they'll just say you're an
idiot Pearl's not married blah blah blah
and that's when you know you won because
because
they got nothing better to say so
here's to the
the
crazy people the whales
sorry not Wales beautiful majestic
creatures
um
the women the salty women in the
comments oh pearls so it's like then
they can't pick they're like pearls so
unattractive that she gets no attention
from men but then they'll say I am an
old of model it's like can we pick a
struggle here
ah can we pick a struggle here
which one wait I just I just want I just
would like one to be picked
you know and so as a woman you know it's
quite hard for me to not read the
comments and separate it right my
producer says I just should not read the
comments but it's very hard guys it's uh
because I like interacting with the fans
I like butt and I really do read a lot
of the comments
but
I think I'm just gonna stop soon I need
to stop because it's just it's not
helpful it's like
you know
I'm out here living life
and then a comment will just say
I'm just like
give their analysis of me it's just you
know
okay and they usually do this to Kevin
Samuels too and I did it you know what I
mean I I you know maybe this is what
goes around comes around because I
remember saying
and it really didn't hit me what he was
doing until later because okay I would
say well why is he giving marriage
advice he's not married he was never
giving marriage advice not really
anyways
he would look at outcomes and you talk
to so many people you start to see the
outcomes like this type of girl does
this this happens this type of girl does
that that happens tendency these these
type of women so the most traditional
women have this type of outcomes they're
usually married by 25.
now does that mean a hundred percent
does that mean there's not exceptions no
but
you see what I'm saying you see what I'm
saying so
it's like
and that's what I I realized Kevin was
analyzing it like I used to analyze
things in sales like when I was in sales
I would um
I would ask qualifying questions and
that's what Kevin Samuels would do on
the phone he would say like are you
married how much do you weigh that's
like the same way you would qualify like
for a copier when I worked in copier
sales I would say like all right do you
staple do you do this do you do that
like you know just to configure The
copier
um how much do you print a month you
know and
so you know that's what I realized
they're triggered they can stay
triggered they can call me dumb they can
call me whatever
I don't really care I'm gonna
I'll be here you know on YouTube so
yeah anyways like the video on your way
out for real
sign up for the email list I'm trying to
collect some emails like the video on
your way out and I'll talk to you next
time